les soldes divers qui ont débuté hier
pour ce coup d'envoient il n'y avait pas
de il n'y avait pas foule dans les
magasins 56 mois avec nous pour en
parler Caroline Lee bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes gérant de deux boutiques
indépendantes à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
il y a Tiffany elle et Créafil alors
comment ça se passe les soldes quand on
est gérante une boutique indépendante
c'est plus compliqué que que si on était
des une grande enseigne parce que on
doit tout étiqueter c'est pas toujours
évident et nous c'est des vrais soldes
c'est à dire c'est vraiment
le stock de l'année en cours
Conrad était a été et hiver à hiver on
n'a pas de plan de stockage on a pas de
d'endroit où stocker la marchandise si
on la vend pas donc on est obligé de
vraiment brader nos articles pour
pouvoir par la suite commander notre
collection d'été et alors justement vous
les brader jusqu'à jusqu'à combien vos
articles 50 60
ça dépend des produits puisque en
réalité comme on est indépendant on fait
des tout petits prix en vrai on
travaille vraiment toute l'année on
travaille mieux hors sol que pendant les
soldes et ça fonctionne encore cette
année les
c'est vrai que les soldes ne veut plus
rien dire parce que on est promotion sur
promotion dans les autres boutiques même
si nous on ne l'est pas vraiment mais
serait tout au long de l'année on fait
des petits prix ou des fin de série pour
les dernières pièces ou qui qui restent
ce qui fait que pendant les soldes oui
on solde vraiment les plus grosses
pièces ou les bottes qui vont nous
prendre beaucoup de place et qui n'ont
plus leur place en rayon pour l'été
Gabriel est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les gens attendent
moins la période des soldes pour acheter
aujourd'hui on a plus tendance à avoir
un achat immédiat non alors chez nous
oui ils ont vraiment le coup de coeur
les gens c'est au coup de cœur peu
importe il faut qu'ils aiment le produit
et du monde qu'ils aiment ils vont
acheter Joséphine conasse Berger a
plaisir vous avez de nombreux centres
commerciaux c'est important cette
période des soldes pour la ville ça a
l'air puisque hier j'y étais je suis
allée voir un petit peu la température
il y avait énormément de monde alors
c'est vrai que si on était mercredi mais
il y avait vraiment beaucoup de monde
dans les magasins alors après pour le
chiffre d'affaires je n'en sais rien
mais enfin au vu des queues qu'il y
avait dans dans les magasins devant les
caisses il y a certaines grandes marques
comme disait madame qui effectivement
fonctionne très très bien après tous les
magasins n'ont pas je dirais cet
engouement là mais je ferai mon ma
petite enquête mais je pense que les
choses se sont pas trop mal passées donc
il y a cette différence là entre les
centres commerciaux et les boutiques un
peu plus indépendantes ça vous touche
vous Caroline non ça fait quand même 20
ans qu'on est sur place donc on a
vraiment notre clientèle très fidèle que
je remercie d'ailleurs mais
non je pense que on est vraiment une
équipe très dynamique qui fait que les
gens reviennent facilement nous voir
depuis combien de temps est-ce que vous
êtes gérante de ces deux boutiques
depuis 2005 pour le prêt-à-porter
tiffaniel et on a récupéré la mercerie
il y a deux ans la personne elle partait
à la retraite je me disais bête de
laisser mourir une mercerie surtout
qu'il y en a plus
donc on est pratiquement l'un des seuls
et rares de notre espèce donc ça fait de
nombreuses années est-ce que du coup ça
fait depuis assez longtemps que vous
voyez qu'il y a un manque un petit peu
d'engouement pour les soldes comme je
dis le manque d'engouement pour les sols
c'est fait c'est le fait que les gens
bénéficient de promotion tout au long de
l'année donc ils attendent plus
forcément les soldes pour acheter
et donc nous sommes allés poser la
question aux yvelinesois pourquoi
pourquoi ils ne font plus les soldes les
propos recueillis par Ludivine canard et
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude et Régine
ralech j'ai presque le mode normal
maintenant et puis des sols sur internet
il y en a tout le temps aussi en fait la
pression que ça donne c'est que le vrai
prix c'est les soldes et puis il reste
du temps c'est de l'arnaque pas grand
chose parce que il y a pas mal d'oeufs
sur Internet et du coup on fait plutôt
en cours d'année enfin tout le long de
l'année que plutôt attendre le moment
des sols pour le faire
donc les soldes il y a plus grand chose
maintenant je trouve ça sert à rien
c'est il y a trop de choses en jeu tout
va bien qu'à prendre un prix correct
tout le temps c'est bon ça suffit on
n'est pas spécialement obligé d'attendre
la période des soldes en elle-même
puisque il y en a dans le courant de
l'année exactement donc quand j'ai des
besoins je peux en profiter aussi dans
le Coran de l'année alors on l'entend
dans ce micro-trottoir les Yvelinois
préfèrent les ventes privées ou acheter
sur internet votre réaction par rapport
à tout ça Caroline Lee c'est vrai que on
est très surchargé d'informations
d'envies sur Internet on est souvent sur
notre smartphone donc forcément on a
plus d'envies mais n'empêche que
que les gens viennent quand même en
magasin j'ai cette impression que nous
en tout cas par rapport à la mercerie
les gens viennent et font des choses par
eux-mêmes et ont envie de préserver les
boutiques sur place donc ils se déplace
on voit qu'il se déplace vous comptez
faire les soldes autour de ce plateau
vous venez de nous rejoindre vous allez
faire votre chronique sur les animaux
dans peu de temps mais est-ce que vous
comptez faire les soldes alors je compte
bien faire les soldes j'ai pas encore
commencé hier j'attends toujours la
deuxième démarque
pas forcément parce que c'est vrai qu'il
y a des promotions assez régulièrement
donc je vois pas forcément là beaucoup
la différence et vous Joséphine
colmarger j'arrive à me laisser tenter
c'est sûr si je me promène un peu je
trouve toujours quelque chose qui
m'intéresse c'est sûr et alors au niveau
de votre chiffre d'affaires Caroline ni
est-ce que vous voyez une différence les
sols ça marque une différence pour nous
pas particulièrement les seuls parce que
c'est pas un moment phare de notre de
notre activité c'est vraiment lisser sur
toute l'année on a cette chance là que
c'est pas vraiment que les soldes ce qui
nous permet de travailler parce qu'en
vrai en période de sol on ne travaille
pas on ne fait que liquider notre stock
on récupère une trésorerie c'est pas ça
qui nous fait vivre si on est en solde
toute l'année on coule clairement
c'est pas possible merci beaucoup
Caroline ni d'avoir accepté notre
invitation les soldes se poursuivent
jusqu'au 7 février